for 300 years the Targaryen dynasty
ruled Westeros wars were still fought
homes still burn and men still died but
compared to the chaos of what came
before the realm was stable and boring
the Targaryen slide thieved and killed
as much as other lords they just had
dragons to answer all complaints until
they didn't when the last dragon died it
was only a matter of time before the
Targaryens followed by only you mean
another century which they wasted trying
to replace their lost advantage
incinerating their own palaces to hatch
dragon eggs drinking wildfire to become
dragons and let's not forget the mad
Kings favorite burning men alive so he
could pretend to be a dragon we urged
Aerys to pardon Brandon Stark
the boy had threatened Prince Rhaegar
but Rhaegar had stolen the boy's sister
and the boy was the eldest son of our
warden of the north
who's the greater fool a Mad King or the
man who reasons with him Aerys saw
knives in every shadow when you told him
to treat the Starks with caution
you made him afraid and what he feared
he killed I wouldn't have thought you of
all people would bother with
recriminations for Brandon's death Lord
Baelish
not after you're shall we call it duel
with him
Brandon was as arrogant as he was stupid
like his father
Lord Stark who answered Aerys his son
into the capital they earned their fates
but the younger son Ned what was his
crime
that Aerys ordered his death as well
unlike men families don't die when you
lop off their head
at the very least you should have
pointed out that loyal and dutiful Ned
was living with John Aaron a proud and
over righteous Lord with an impregnable
castle and no sons of his own perhaps
you could have spared Aerys the
embarrassment of revolt if only we'd had
the foresight to consult you Lord
Baelish but I suppose first we'd have
had to know who you were
nobody knew Robert Baratheon either yet
he claimed the right to sit on the Iron
Throne
he had Targaryen blood through his
mother a pretty dress for an ugly truth
it was war and he could swing a hammer
harder than the other options when did
you know you'd lost Lord Varys
when Robert Baratheon killed Prince
Rhaegar on the Trident wrong you lost
the war when you let Ned Stark slip back
into the north
neither the bloody gate of the Vale a
moat Cailin in the north have ever
fallen they could have held out for
years even if you'd killed Robert but
you let him slip through your fingers as
well I told the court that Robert was
hiding in the Stoney Sept with the hand
of the king wasted too much time
searching the city something about the
glory of single combat then Ned Stark's
army arrived to save the day
too bad Lord Tywin wasn't hand any
longer he would have simply raised the
town and been done with it perhaps and
perhaps the rebels would have found even
more of the countryside flocking to
their banners I'd almost forgotten you
weren't always so loyal to the
Lannisters during the war why are you I
did my duty to the realm when Lord Tywin
showed up at King's Landing professing
loyalty I warned Arras not open the
gates Prince Rhaegar was dead our army
scattered the lion does not stir unless
he smells meat I admire your powers of
persuasion Lord Varys you could traffic
in so many secrets to so little of
grand maester pycelle told ares what he
wanted to hear that his old friend Tywin
was there to save him then Aerys old
friend sacked the city and his son
stabbed Aerys in the back I regrettable
though necessary action as where the
pardons the new King Robert bestowed on
the Royalists mace Tyrell Barristan
Selmy you
King Robert wisely chose order over
vengeance Jon Arryn wisely chose for
Robert but Jon Arryn died then Robert
then Ned so ended the Glorious
Revolution and Westeros has been burning
ever since that it how Targaryen of you
one of the mad ones
fire turns even the proudest Oaks to ash
leaving new arutz space to climb